alcool absence de distanciation de port
du masque jusqu'à l' usage de vva
porteuse en plein vol la fed y voi
nolisés de sunwing du 30 décembre
dernier est désormais sous enquête par
le gouvernement fédéral je peux vous
assurer
que transports canada prend très au
sérieux la situation avec ce vol nolisé
du new york post aux états unis au daily
mail en angleterre les gestes et
comportements du groupe de 150
influenceurs ont fait le tour du monde
au cours des derniers jours l'avion avec
peu de centaines de passagers à 30 mille
pieds ce n'est pas un chalet dans la
forêt dans lesquels on peut tout faire
bien au chaud sur les plages du mexique
plusieurs fêtards ont produit des vidéos
pour narguer ceux qui désapprouvaient
leurs gestes et comportements
en plus quand les gens sont en train de
faire les sacrifices
et jean centre en ont réduit leurs
contacts pendant le temps des fêtes on
pas vu des êtres chers et quand tu
gagnes 200 dessins qui décide de partir
comme des ostrogoths en vacances
c'est pas et
c'est extrêmement frustrant de plus
certains membres du groupe de fêtards
qui cherche maintenant à rentrer au
canada se sont partagé des conseils pour
éviter l' isolement obligatoire en cas
de test positif à la coke vide
c'est peut-être finalement la justice
qui va ramener ces influenceurs sur
terre pour un non respect de la
réglementation aérienne
la loi prévoit des amendes jusqu'à 5000
$ par infraction pour une fausse
déclaration lors de son entrée au canada
il est prévu des amendes jusqu'à 750
mille dollars ou encore six mois
d'emprisonnement et finalement pour
mettre en danger la vie d'autrui lors
d'un vol il est prévu des amendes
jusqu'à 1 million $ ou encore trois ans
d'emprisonnement et je vois pas une
marque ou une entreprise qui voudraient
s'associer à nouveau pour une
collaboration pour la promotion d'un
produit avec ces gens là cette situation
l'a eu un impact très négatif
la fonction marketing influence pour
l'heure c'est plutôt de trouver le moyen
de rentrer au pays qui préoccupent les
membres du groupe des fluence heures car
plusieurs transporteurs aériens refuse
maintenant de les prendre à bord de
leurs appareils ici pascal robidas
radio-canada à montréal